c'est l'heure de notre grand entretien
nous recevons ce soir le journaliste
samuel laurent il a passé des mois des
années a observé les réseaux sociaux et
à s'en servir lui-même il a fini par se
brûler les ailes par faire l'objet d'
insulte d'attac de harcèlement
aujourd'hui il alerte dans un livre
qu'il a intitulé j'ai vu naître le
monstre twitter va-t-il tuer la
démocratie
on va en parler longuement avec lui dans
un instant voyons d'abord le reportage
de marion delpech et de juliette jonas
qui ont suivi des tweetos averti très
actif et dont les avis divergent sur le
sujet regardez entre deux patients le
chef des urgences de l'hôpital de saint
denis s'adonne à son passe temps favori
le clash sur twitter entraînant son lot
de dérives
j'ai eu des menaces de mort des menaces
ya l'histoire de nuremberg vargo et
raciste voilà qui a un lien aussi avec
l'activité politique de ma femme
donc en général je ne réponds pas sur
les tweets qui critiquent ma femme
docteur ultra médiatisé
mathias baron mari de la ministre
emmanuelle wargon réuni 33 mille abonnés
sur son compte
une notoriété qu'il a appris à maîtriser
tout seul mais compte bloqué ils sont là
en comble ok j'en ai 2015 avec trois
plaintes à son actif c'est addicts du
débat en ligne se sont parfois démunis
face aux cyber harcèlement
ils alertent sur les dysfonctionnements
de la plate forme et c'est pas une
question de liberté d'expression
tout le monde peut s'exprimer c'est une
question d'un moment il ya des limites
qui sont bas les menaces de l'orse quand
vous menacer quelqu'un de mort ou de
prison ou de jeu pas quoi de collabo
enfin des conneries comme ça
balas et la limite et la personne les
fous dehors et c'est sûr que twitter ne
fait pas son travail
une polarisation de la violence due aux
formats seulement 280 caractère pour
exprimer son opinion laissant peu de
place pour la nuance giussepe des
martineau connais bien cette culture du
clash
il préside une association de défense de
la liberté d'expression sur les
plateformes
son constat journalistes et politiques
raffolent de twitter ils y sont les plus
présents aux côtés d' individus plus
malveillant pacifique
t'es con qu'on peut avoir c'est que
également sur twitter prospère
foisonnent ce qu'on appelle des trolls
des gens qui systématiquement prennent
l'avis contraire de ce qui suit ce qui
donne une position et ça crée évidemment
des animosités une acrimonie toujours
présente et quelques quelques excès
quelques problèmes qu'on a pu voir
encore récemment le cas de samuel patti
ou encore la ferme il a questionné sur
l'absence de modération sur la
plateforme
l'avocat jean-pierre mignard plaident
pour qu'elle soit collective provenant à
la fois des utilisateurs des plateformes
et des autorités administratives
la technologie peut être quand même mené
2 1 et de considérables mais à la fin
des fins c'est bien les réseaux et
plateformes qui devront faire qu'ils
vont encadrer parce que sinon aucun
service public de surveillance ne le
pourra il intervient en dernier lieu
dans le cadre de la sanction ça c'est
les juges une certaine manière feu comme
un jardinier sur internet et en sorte
que les plates-bandes existe là où il ya
des gerbes qui viennent eux corrompre
les autres on les enlève
mais toute heure est à nouveau grand
jardin de la démocratie en mai 2000
vingt six associations françaises
avaient assigné twitter en justice
estimant que le réseau manqué à ses
obligations de modération après l'échec
d'une médiation ces structures demandent
aujourd'hui une expertise et c'est
vraiment le sujet des décennies à venir
bienvenue samuel laurent merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je disais vous
êtes journaliste au monde ancien
responsable des décodeurs vous publiez
donc ce livre j'ai vu naître le monstre
twitter va-t-il tuer la démocratie on
entendu différents témoignages dans ce
reportage de marion ceux qui saluent le
débat d'idées sur twitter ce qui déplore
aussi les faits qui nous absolument
ahurissante
racontez-nous votre vécu à vous ce que
vous racontez dans votre livre est ce
qui vous a amené à voir du monstrueux
dans twitter en fait ce que j'essaye de
raconter dans mon livre c'est qu'il ya
d'une part mon parcours à moi qui suis
d'un journaliste qui a commencé dans ce
métier en même temps que twitter dont
qui étaient très présents différents
partie de cette génération journalistes
issus des sites web qui était beaucoup
beaucoup sur cette plateforme
à qui elle a permis de grandir
professionnellement évidemment à qui
elle a offert un tas d'opportunités
professionnelles et puis c'est aussi
l'histoire de twitter et de comment ce
canal l'a particulièrement est devenu
c'est ce qui est dit par des
interruptions dans le reportage centrale
dans le débat public français parce que
c'est la plateforme des journalistes des
politiques et des communicants le
problème c'est que twitter n'est pas la
plateforme des français s'il devait y
aura une plateforme des français se
seraient facebook quiconque qui a à peu
près 40 millions de français qui sont
sur facebook y en a que quatre millions
sur twitter
c'est alors que twitter est devenu le
lieu central l'agora central des débats
mais c'est une agora qui est coupée
finalement delà de la grande majorité
des gens donc c'est un salon parisien en
fait twitter qui aujourd'hui prend une
importance qui est disproportionné à mon
sens par rapport à ce que ça peut
représenter dans l'actualité et on le
sait on le voit tous les jours twitter
façonnent le débat public
et là problème c'est que la grammaire de
twitter qui est une grammaire de clash
qui ne ramènent de violence qu'on peut
pas développer d'arguments où on crée
des camps qui s'opposent
cette grammaire elle ce transfert dans
le débat public et dans débat politique
aujourd'hui et c'est à mon sens un
problème et vous vous êtes brûler les
ailes si vous avez vous même vécu des
campagnes de cyber harcèlement
moi j'en ai vécu plusieurs j'en ai même
vécu tout au long de ma carrière parce
que l'une des parties de l'activité des
décodeurs c'était de faire de la
vérification factuel et qu'évidemment
quand vous donner tort un politique ou
un parti vous vous prenez ces militants
sur la tête et que aujourd'hui tous les
partis sans exception ont désarmé de
militants qui sont mobilisables pour
aller taper sur les journalistes et que
c'est vraiment devenu une stratégie de
communication complètement banale des
insoumis à la république en marche tout
le monde possède son armée de trolls et
tout le monde des chaînes sont un mets
troll sur le sur l'adversaire avec la
problématique que du coup on est tombé
dans une fabrique d'un récit puisque sur
twitter ce qui compte c'est pas la
vérité c'est le récit essaie d'imposer
un récit donc mal la chose qui m'a fait
partir twitter ces trois mois de
harcèlement des partisans de la
république en marche qui ont pour base
une intox balancé par christophe
castaner à l'époque sur des gilet jaune
qui serait rentré dans l'hôpital la
pitié salpêtrière où on avait parlé
d'une d'une intrusion violente où il
aurait renversé et c'est qu'ils étaient
fausses castaner a reconnu qu'elle était
fausse et le simple fait que nous on
dise que c'était faux ça suffit a
déchaîné les partisans à l'om pendant
des mois et des mois qu'ils voulaient
absolument imposer ce récit des gilet
jaune comme des factieux violent donc il
fallait absolument que ça ça a existé et
c'est je pense aujourd'hui quelque chose
d'assez délétère à une problématique
pour la démocratie d'avoir ce type de
comportement de meute
type de choses qui sont admises voire
encouragée dans les parties mais vous
parlez des militants des communicants
des journalistes des responsables
politiques comme si aucun français
n'était sur twitter mais il ya aussi des
campagnes de harcèlement venant des
français lambda évidemment des français
enfin gérard 8h est même devenu presque
un peu la discussion qu'on pouvait avoir
au café ou au comptoir d'un café et qui
aujourd'hui est public ce sont aussi des
français bien sûr mais c'est 4 millions
de français pape à 40 millions quand ils
allaient gilet jaune qui sortent gijoe
ne sont pas sur twitter pourquoi
pourquoi on les a pas vus parce que tous
les journalistes et tous les politiques
de france ne regarde que twitter est à
mon sens le problème est aussi là on
regarde pas assez d eau plate forme et
autres espaces on regarde pas assez ce
qui s'y passe alors qui s'y passe
énormément de choses et on se concentre
sur ce réseau où effectivement vous avez
raison il ya des français lambda il ya
un twitter du football et un tweeter
manga il ya des tas de communauté mais
c'est encore une fois de petites
communautés et en général les
communautés de gens qui ont des choses à
dire beaucoup plus que les autres
plateformes beaucoup plus qu'un cas
médias comme facebook sur facebook pour
caricaturer vous allez avoir votre beau
frère votre grand mère ou votre cousin
qui est pas très impliquée dans des
voies là et sur twitter vous allez avoir
des étudiants vous allez avoir des des
gens qui ont des choses à gérer
revendiquer des chercheurs des je pense
à des fans de foot aussi mais ça marche
aussi d'en conduire cette dimension
d'avoir envie de dire des choses d'avoir
envie d'être baladées dans une
communauté
évidemment je généralise évidemment il
ya aussi des gens qui sont totalement
lambda qui vont sur twitter pour faire
des blagues et heureusement d'ailleurs
que c'est pas que un réseau mais voilà
il ya cette problématique de on accorde
énormément d'importance nous
journalistes et nous politique à ce
réseau là au détriment finalement tous
les autres ces derniers jours on a
beaucoup parlé et reparlé de l'âge et
demi la victime elle aussi sur twitter
l'homme se sait beaucoup sur instagram
il arrondit twitter mais en fait c'était
essentiellement stargaard c'était
essentiellement instagram les messages
qu'elle a reçu les cent mille messages
haineux qu'elle a reçue c'est
essentiellement un seul avait un peu de
tout après c'était instagram facebook
twitter je sais pas comment ils ont
comptabilisé 6 à les messages qui lui
étaient adressées aussi c'est des gens
qui parlaient de millas qui utilisait le
hashtag millar exactement alors il ya eu
aussi en début de semaine les insultes
visant jean luc mélenchon
une vidéo qui a simulé l'exécution a là
aussi c'était youtube donc plus
globalement si on revient aux réseaux
sociaux à la lueur de ce que vous avez
vécu
finalement vous direz que vous n'êtes
pas surpris par la tournure que prennent
les événements non pas du tout alors on
parle on parle de choses assez
différentes millas est effectivement
d'une part ses instincts g qui est un
autre public qui je pense est plus jeune
on est dans un cercle plus adolescent où
elle même
sur cette vidéo ça devient une espèce de
phénomène global sert tout le monde en
parle et elle devient la cible deux
centaines de milliers de jeunes adultes
de jeunes adolescents qui s'en prennent
à elle comme effectivement c'est arrivé
dans d'autres cas et pour d'autres
personnalités
là c'est vrai qu'on a atteint un degré
de violence et dans le nombre et dans
l'intensité de ce qui lui est envoyée
qui est assez inquiet c'est fascinant et
qui est assez hallucinant maintenant des
histoires comme ça il en existe
malheureusement presque tous les jours
après si on prend le cas de papa site ok
donc sur youtube heures d'extrême droite
qui a fait cette vidéo je voulais pas
cité son nom pour moi c'est encore une
autre communauté qui est une communauté
que là aussi on n'a peut-être pas assez
raconter parce qu'elle existe en fait
depuis une dizaine d'années c'est cette
communauté de youtube heures viriliste
nationaliste masculinistes d'extrême
droite qui sont très influents auprès
d'un public de jeunes hommes fans de
jeux vidéo notamment auprès de
communautés comme celle du forum 18 25
et qui mènent une espèce de guerre
culturelle je dis à papa si tôt dans sa
dernière vidéo ils l'expliquent il le
dit clairement on est dans une guerre
culturelle on en train de la gagner et
je pense que c'est pas faux serre qui
sont dans un truc de par le rire par
l'outrance et sait faire passer
distiller des idées d'extrême droite
extrême rade violente on parle comme
vous parle même pas du fn 1ère droite du
fn et qu'ils y arrivent qu'ils arrivent
à imposer des codes culturels qui
s'impose petit à petit dans le débat le
terme de fragile par exemple lui c'est
un fragile ou d'hommes soja ou ce qu'ils
sont vraiment du langage 10 succès de
ces communautés là se diffuse petit à
petit et va être repris y compris par
des politiques florian philippot prendre
un exemple dans la dernière campagne
s'amuser à faire des tas de petites
allusions dans ces vidéos dans ses
interventions médias à ces communautés
là parce qu'il sait qu'elles sont très
actives et très forte culturellement
s'ils se reconnaissent ils se parlent
entre eux via
alors utilisé un personnage s'appelle
résister à ce qui est vraiment personne
ajoute qu' un comique mexicain je crois
qui est un personnage emblématique du 25
il avait collé sous une susan boyle et
quand il faisait ses vidéos il devait
résister c'était clairement un petit
signal envoyé à ces gens là
le summum de l'horreur liés aux réseaux
sociaux et à twitter enfin je crois
peut-être que vous allez me dire le
contraire c'est quand même ce qui est
arrivé à samuel pâtit est-ce que là vous
avez été surpris quand même que ça alors
ça m'épate hills et facebook le coup
enfin les vidéos mois pour le coup j'ai
vu aussi visant le père en fait qui a
fait cette vidéo très énervé et c'était
facebook ça mais le bâti c'est
effectivement le cas de la rumeur sur
les réseaux sociaux de manière générale
c'est à dire des gens s'enflamment sur
un truc qui nous ils ne sont pas qu'ils
n'ont pas vu sur la foi d'un témoignage
et ça on l'a tous les jours sur les
réseaux c'est à dire qu'il suffit mais
c'est terrible parce qu'en fait ça nous
prend à défaut les réseaux sociaux parce
que ça manipule nos émotions
ça touche nos émotions notre affect
n'est pas notre raison donc quand vous
avez une personne qui fait un témoignage
sur un réseau social en général ce
témoignage peut être relayé des
centaines des milliers de fois peu de
gens vont aller vérifier la véracité du
témoignage en effet de faire ça on va
partir du principe que la personne est
de bonne foi et c'est exactement ce qui
se passe là et puis surtout on va
commencer à s'énerver ont éprouvé de
l'empathie on va trouver ça scandaleux
on va trouver ça va nous mettre en
colère et une fois qu'on a éprouvé de
l'émotion c'est très difficile de
revenir à la raison
et là typiquement on est vraiment dans
ce cas là c'est à dire que c'est la
vidéo du père qui déclenche un mouvement
sur les réseaux tout le monde en parle
jusqu'à ce que sa atteignent ce jeune
terroriste heures futurs terroristes
assassins tchétchène par le biais des
réseaux sociaux et de cette espèce de
rumeurs qui se propagent et sans que
personne à aucun moment ni été
questionné l'arrêt de la véracité du
témoignage qui en plus s'est avéré
largement erronée donc on est sur un
soin sur un phénomène de rumeurs qui
pour le coup est peut-être plus anciens
on peut penser à la rumeur de nantes
dans les années 60 je crois que 50 mais
c'est vrai que les réseaux sociaux
démultiplie ce type de procès ce parce
qu'encore une fois qu'ils sont pas appel
à notre ils font pas la peine un autre
raisonnement et c'est un de leurs gros
problème c'est qu'ils font appel à nos
émotions et quand vous êtes beaucoup sur
twitter vous passez votre temps à être
en colère car l'autre ils parlent pas
auxerre voilà et vous passez votre temps
est pas content être en colère à être
indignés a trouvé d'ailleurs certain
vocabulaire qui est très souvent
utilisée c'est à vomir c'est et du coup
ça favorise pas du tout la réflexion le
raisonnement il a nuancé en plus la
brièveté des messages et des échanges
fait que
en général plus dans l'affectif que dans
la recherche d'une position médiane
jusqu'où ça peut nous amener selon vous
tous là on a vu un produit social
sociétal politique jusqu'où ça peut
aller assez loin et malheureusement très
loin je pense qu'on a vu aux états unis
ce que ça pouvait donner avec avec
donald trump et avec aujourd'hui avec
laquelle la crise du coc vide on voit
bien aussi
moi c'est un truc qui me fait très peur
depuis quelques mois c'est de voir à
quel point le discours
conspirationnistes qui l'a aussi n'a pas
le bas n'a pas attendu les réseaux
sociaux pour la pour exister
ça a toujours été mais à quel point il
se centralise c'est à dire à quel point
vous avez des gens qui seraient qui
était au delà de tout soupçon qui
étaient des élites intellectuelles des
avis scientifiques qui vont aller
basculer dans ce type de raisonnement et
à quel point vous pouvez voir des gens
partir loin c'est à dire n'être plus du
tout du tout connecté au réel et refusé
mordicus de connecteurs réel ce qui est
terrifiant avec les réseaux sociaux et
avec et avec cela internet c'est aussi
qu'il ya une tel foisonnement
d'informations vraies ou fausses que
finalement si vous croyez quelque chose
vous trouverez toujours un média qui va
vous qui va vous dire ce que vous croyez
si vous cherchez des trucs qui vous
disent que le corps d'un virus est un
complot global dirigé par bill gates
pour implanter des puces 5 g ou je ne
sais quoi vous allez trouver des
centaines et des centaines et des
centaines de vidéos de textes de ce que
vous voulez qu'ils vont vous dire oui
oui c'est vrai regardez on a les preuves
et moi ce qui m'effraie c'est de voir
des scientifiques des gens qui voient là
qui normalement devrait pas tomber là
dedans plonger là dedans et il ne pas en
ressortir en général parce qu'ils
follement paradoxal c'est qu'au départ
le réseau social et en l'occurrence
twitter c'est le lieu même de la
démocratie de l'expression de l' échange
et c'est devenu l'inversé vous dites que
c'est en train de tuer où ça va
peut-être tué la démocratie tout cas je
pense que ça la modifie parce
qu'effectivement je pense qu'un autre
souci c'est que si c'était si ça ne
concernait que des jeunes guides qui
parlait de jeux vidéo dans leur coin à
la limite ce serait pas très grave le
souci c'est que quand vous avez
aujourd'hui sur des réseaux sociaux
comme twitter des ministres qui vont
répondre à des gens qui vont passer un
certain temps de leur journée moi ça me
fascine regarder des gens que marlène
schiappa le temps qu'elle peut passer
l'activité qu'elle peut déployer sur ce
réseau partiel ou ses équipes elles ou c
est qu il ait jamais trop si c'est votre
cas
et de se dire mais pourquoi celui-là
pourquoi pas un autre et qui finalement
est ce qu'il y a pas un qui a pas autre
chose à faire dans la dans la journée
leurs ministres sa réputation sont bien
sûr mais ce sont aussi des hommes et des
femmes à qui on pourrait reprocher de ne
pas être assez connecter aux français de
ne pas être assez serait connecté au
réseau social justement dépassement est
ce qu'ils ont l'air
il centre au leader troyen s'est
vraiment les français ou est-ce que
c'est pas plutôt les médias qui
cherchent à toucher et nous journalistes
on a une énorme part de responsabilité
là dedans on est complètement drogué à
ce réseau on est les premiers addict à
ce réseau et je dis ça moi je m'en suis
parti je m'exprime plus je peux pas non
plus totalement mon abstraire ce serait
très difficile voire impossible de faire
mon travail
typiquement pour citer papa tito est le
cas du jeune homme qui a giflé d'amiante
et qui a giflé emmanuel macron dans les
deux cas j'ai eu besoin d'aller sur les
réseaux sociaux pour les retrouver ses
terres professionnellement je pourrais
pas m'en passer
est on est on est devenus complètement
prisonnier de ces espaces qui sont des
espaces qui sont privées qui sont pas
une agora public par ailleurs on a
tendance à penser que c'est un raisin
tuyaux neutre ce pas un tuyau notre
marshall mc luhan qui a intéressé à la
communication faisait dans les années 60
le média fait le message est le média
twitter amène une forme de message qui
est violente qui est celle du clash qui
essayent de la de la brièveté de la
division ans quand et dans quelle mesure
tout ça ne fusent pas notre débat
démocratique de manière délétère et de
manière dangereuse ses larmes une
question qu'il faudrait que nos
journalistes ne pouvaient pas nous
politiques et aux politiques se posent
peut-être de manière un peu plus parce
que c'est pas un tuyau notre quoi je me
fais l'avocat du diable volontairement
même si évidemment je j'entends
complètement ce que vous dites mais
twitter a aussi au moins en tout cas au
début eu des effets très positifs pour
libérer les populations arabes par
exemple de leurs dictateurs en tunisie
ça a d'abord plutôt actifs facebook
lorsque j'allais dire le premier exemple
qui est l egypte dont l'egypte est pas
spécialement libéré dix ans après mai
mais oui mais c'est une question est ce
que à un moment donné quand même ça a eu
un effet libérateur un effet positif et
d'ailleurs est ce que ça peut donner de
l'espoir pour que ça redevienne un des
réseaux sociaux positifs
est ce que vous y croyez ou est-ce que
vous ne croyez plus du tout je pense
qu'il ya un effet il ya un effet positif
et toute façon on ne peut pas partir du
principe qu'il faut les interdire ce
serait ridicule ils sont dans le paysage
il existe on fonctionne avec ce serait
impossible je pense que ça tient
vraiment d'une part à la responsabilité
des non pas des gars femmes pas pas
forcément que des gars femmes ce que
twitter n'est pas un gars femmes mais
dde des kills opérateurs de ces
plateformes pardon qui sont qui pour le
coup n'ont pas tellement intérêt à un
des soucis de ces réseaux c'est que au
départ sur internet il ya eu des
discussions s'étaient sur des forums sur
les forums dès lors qu'on a commencé à
discuter on a inventé la mode et ça on a
mis en place de la modération
parce que si vous organisez n'importe
quel débat mais mon réel vous avez
besoin d'un modérateur pour que les gens
puissent s'exprimer
les plateformes la promesse qu'elles ont
faite c'est de dire il ya plus besoin de
modération nous on vous fournit les
tuyaux et débrouillez vous avec les
tweeters particulièrement a toujours dit
ça a dit nous on est la liberté parole
absolue mais est ce qu'on peut avoir une
liberté de parole absolue sans
modération non le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya tellement de monde
sur ses plates formes que ce serait
impossible techniquement de faire de la
modération
facebook avait fait le calcul froid qui
disent qu'il faut mettre deux cent mille
personnes pour arriver à modérer tout ce
qui est publié sur facebook
donc c'est colossal et donc c'est passé
pas dans leur c'est pas dans leur
intérêt
après oui c'est raison des effets
positifs faut pas non plus voilà il ya
de la libération de la parole via le
fait que des pertes des minorités
puissent s'exprimer sans twitter est ce
que réussit tout sans twitter assure
fait la malle un sas curie des
mouvements comme ça sans doute pas qu'il
ya effectivement des choses très
positives qu'il faut pas qu'elles sont
il faut pas à cacher il ya des tas de
kde de gens qui sont pu se sortir de
situations très difficiles grâce aux
réseaux sociaux
il a de l'entr'aide ya des tas de choses
positives évidemment qu'il faut pas
minorer encore une fois je pense que le
problème ce n'est pas tant ça c'est dans
quelle mesure on en fait un espace
central et dans quelle mesure on est
prisonnier de sa grammaire et
particulièrement dans le débat politique
aujourd'hui je dirais cirque aujourd'hui
vous avez des forces comme les
identitaires français qui numériquement
ne pèse rien s'ils se présenter aux
élections demain il fera 0 2% mais qui
arrive à mener une guerre culturelle
très puissante
via ces outils là parce que c'est un
effet de levier terrine effet zoom
en effet ce bouquin aucune oblige les
dessins en permanence et en fait on
offre une parce qu'après une fois que
vous êtes vous avez du succès sur
twitter en général les chaînes d'info
vont venir vous chercher pour aller dans
des débats et ainsi de suite et c'est
vrai que je pense que ça tient
essentiellement pas tant aux plateformes
que à la manière dont nous les
communicants les journalistes les
universitaires les politiques on les
utilise et on est encore trop naïf par
rapport à ce qu'elles sont alors les
réseaux sociaux ne disparaîtront pas
vous l'avez dit vous-même on est a
priori amené à vivre avec désormais que
faire du coup pour limiter les risques
la casse je voudrais qu'on écoute ce
qu'en disait sur ce plateau le chercheur
serge abiteboul que vous connaissez
peut-être il était la semaine dernière
notre invité dans el pais à l'écouté à
court terme on peut faire des lois on
peut faire de la régulation peut punir
mais à long terme il faut que les les
enfants et la population apprennent à se
comporter à la fois comme consommateurs
sur ces réseaux mais aussi comme
producteur sert savoir comment le
produire comment écrire sur ces réseaux
mais alors finalement si on suit votre
raisonnement c'est pas tant la
population qu'il faut éduquer sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est plutôt finalement
les journalistes les politiques c'est
plutôt ça oui est ce que c'est ça c'est
un truc qu'on dit soins c'est il faut
l'éducation aux médias évidemment à tous
les âges mais on a tendance à dire il
faut éduquer les enfants aux médias
quand vous regardez sur facebook les
groupes conspirationnistes regardez la
moyenne d'âge c'est pas des enfants
c'est même pas des jeunes en général
c'est des gens âgés et ces gens là il
s'est plu beaucoup plus difficile de les
attraper pour leur faire une éducation
aux médias et au fait que news etc sur
internet donc oui il faudrait une
éducation de la population générale et
il faudrait mais ce mais c'est compliqué
parce que c'est des outils qui sont à la
base vécues comme des outils un peu de
loisirs à part pour quelques personnes
qui en font leur métier ça reste des
outils sur lesquels on va pour se
détendre pour s'amuser pour discuter
pour donc on n'est pas censé faire un
permis twitté ce serait un peu compliqué
de l'année comme ça mais effectivement
il ya une éducation à faire qu'on est
peut-être en train de faire
collectivement ici c'est à dire que je
suis on peut imaginer qu'au bout de
vingt ans ça fait dix ans quand même
deux déjà les réseaux sociaux mais en
plus
au bout de vingt ans peut-être qu'on
sera tous un peu mature sur la manière
dont ça fonctionne quand tombera pas
dans les mêmes travers tout cas on peut
l'espérer
ou peut-être que d'autres réseaux aurait
été mise en place avec eux qu'on sortira
de cette gamme erlaubt être que même
menés les opérateurs des réseaux auront
mis en place ce même des choses un
twitter commence à réfléchir à des
petites choses toutes bêtes mais qui
sont ils ont fait un système très bête
qui était dire aux gens quand ils
publient un lien vers un article
est ce que vous avez lu l'article et ben
il est sorti qui montrait que le taux
d'ouverture des articles avaient
augmenté de 40% du ca fonctionne en fait
ce tout petit gars de foule à peut
fonctionner il y avait l'idée de dire on
va laisser un petit délai avant l'envoi
du tweet ou la personne peut supprimer
peut choisir de ne pas l'envoyer ce qui
évite un des soucis de twitter c'est
aussi que ça crée cette espèce décrit
oralisée c'est à dire qu'on est à la
fois dans de l'écrit et on va aller
chercher le tweet qui a publié machin
trois ans avant quatre ans avant il va
être rendue responsable parce que 80 ans
il a répondu ça à telle personne
il ya la fois on est dans une
communication très oral ou en fait on
balance des choses comme ça sans y
réfléchir et parfois à regret donc
peut-être que des petits outils comme ça
de 2,2 mètres un petit délai ça pourrait
aider
en tout cas on peut l'espérer quoi après
show en quelques secondes petit
challenge en désolé parce que nous aussi
on est pris par le temps il faut
regretter la création des réseaux
sociaux selon fu pas à nous on a créé un
monstre est ce qu'il faut se dire que
c'était mieux avant et que parce que
c'était mieux avant non parce que je
pense qu'il ya des choses qu'on voyait
moins avancés c'est le monde tel qu'il
va et c'est comme ça enfin je veux dire
c'est honteux parce qu'il faut que
j'étais l'invention de la télévision
pour prendre un autre exemple il ya du
bon et du mauvais en tout donc c'est
difficile de dire il faudrait il
faudrait revenir à l'époque d'avant les
bains mais quand on voit des événements
comme la terrible la décapitation de
samuel patil et je moi je suis grave
est-ce que ça doit nous faire dire qu'on
a peut-être fait une erreur en créant
ces choses là bas toute façon on n'a pas
en a pas on n'a pas tellement choisi
enfin je veux dire on pourrait choisir
de ne plus y être ou de me plier ses
c'est toujours difficile de voilà le
futur le progrès a toujours des effets
positifs et négatifs je pense qu'après
sur les réseaux sociaux il ya
effectivement un vrai souci de comment
on les utilise et de caisse qui peuvent
donner à l'avenir et c'est vrai que la
vision des tats-unis et pas très
réjouissantes à ce niveau là et la crise
du corona virus a pas donné d super
exemple de ce que ça pouvait donner en
termes de voix la de conspirationnisme
etc maintenant est ce que c'est la faute
aux réseaux sociaux c'est avant tout à
nous je veux dire c'est nous qui en
sommes les utilisateurs donc ça avant
tout à nous de changer
c'est un autre changer on va s'arrêter
là dessus merci infiniment s'améliorant
d'avoir été notre invité ce soir je
rappelle le titre de votre livre
j'ai vu naître le monstre twitter
va-t-il tuer la démocratie merci
infiniment